hall-of-famer Charles Barkley back on
the show how are you Charles I'm doing
great man got no complaints just uh
looking forward to the game at night
trying to figure out how I'm going to
watch Game seven understand the Cup
Finals tonight so I'm really pissed
about that I'm not in the studio I can
have the game on so I got to figure out
how to watch that game somewhere in the
Boston Garden well I mean maybe you
could stream it on your phone or
something like that right
imagine ah you know I'm an
anti-technology I do know social media I
don't I don't even I don't even know how
to stream anything on my phone and but
but you know I gotta watch the game also
so okay well maybe you could have
somebody you know on this I mean just
remind everybody that you're the
reigning Emmy Award winner for best
studio analyst Charles and have somebody
to hand you a device with with that game
going on well I got to make sure I was
there not like a game seven I'm really
looking forward to our game tonight
so how much hockey do you watch normally
you just or is it just because it's an
all-or-nothing game and you like that no
I wants a lot of hockey
you know I became a Flyers fan when I
played for the Sixers going back to Ron
Hextall Eric Lindros those guys and I
have watched pretty mushy that's the
thing when I'm in the studio we have
about 20 televisions in there right no
you know so I've watched from the
beginning of the players I've watched
the game every night basically for the
last two months
mmm Charles Barkley joining me here so
it is not it's not like there's been a
lot of intrigue in the NBA Playoffs on
my makeup playoffs
hey there have been a ton of overtime
games in hockey
they have my god Hillary unbelievable
you know and for some reason I become a
PK szubin fan oh no because I actually
kind of technically now root by the
Blackhawks and I started watching the
predator first round and I knew Pete pka
come for mozzarella over the summer and
I'm like wow these guys are gonna beat
the Chicago Blackhawks so let him cry
yeah crushed him they crushed Tom humble
unbelievable well as if sweep
yeah well in terms of the lack of you
know sizzle on occasion with the NBA
Playoffs with the Cavs coming to those
through one of the where we have
occasional circle well I
guess uh coach fish Dale take that for
data there was that there was a couple
of those here let see that but listen we
knew seven months ago was going to come
down to the Warriors and the Cavaliers
you know the only thing being greed
about this season has been James Harden
and Russell Westbrook gave us an amazing
story line but we knew seven months ago
we started in October it's gonna be okay
what are we gonna do the Buddhist board
regular season there's going to be the
Cavs and the Warriors and finals and you
know that that's a desk only thing to
search for the fans unless you in
Oakland or Cleveland not a lot to cheer
about well what do you do about that
Charles what can be done about it
is there anything if you're Adam
something I don't think you can do
anything about it now I think you know
all these guys want to play together
there's so much money in sports now you
know the new TV deal went from 1 billion
to 2.5 billion dollars a year so a team
like the Warriors can pay to they go on
to play Kevin and step two hundred
million dollars they just gave dream on
100 they don't get a gate clay 800
million and all these guys want to play
together so is it's going to be very
interested in the next few years of the
NBA
Charles Barkley joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show so when these two teams
do meet because we expect it to happen
obviously Cavs and warriors what do you
what do you see happening do you see
that being less of a compelling series
than we expect no I I like the Cavs in
that series why I think because I think
if you look at the series you okay so
this week Kevin and LeBron
that's a matchup clegg don't step
against Kyrie doesn't mess up those
going to cancel each other out and then
it's going to come down to Kevin Love
and Tristan Thompson against the dream
on and whichever big guy weather severe
muggy jajaja to you that to me is a
toss-up those four guys but nobody can
match up with Kyrie and LeBron the in a
one disadvantage for Golden State is the
only way you gonna beat the Cavs to slow
them down because you can't stop LeBron
and you can't stop Kyrie
and this they after going to speed them
two guys up that's why I think that's
why I think they got a really good
chance of being the Warriors in my
opinion so what if clay lights it up
though I mean wouldn't that be the
difference-maker if he's now quickly
well no because Clay's not gonna be
gliding it up because the other two guys
know how to bowl
if you have to watch these game plays a
guy who's suffering the most because of
Kevin and Steph playing great could
think that everybody's been serie you
watch the games the Clay's have not been
great in the play all right that's not
his fault but I think he's the best to
card in the NBA but the problem is you
don't get touches anymore and like a
fake
Kyrie stuff can't guard Kyrie and Kevin
Kevin can't guard LeBron but LeBron can
guard Kevin but uh it's graters Clay is
you don't get touches anymore he
sacrificed a supper board and anybody on
the team charles barkley here on the
Rich Eisen show what do you make of the
news that Danny Ainge let loose today
that the ball family says we're not
working out for you and the Celtics
what's your thoughts on that Charles can
anybody in sports be more disliked than
lunch that the dead-ball I mean this guy
won't let his kid shine I think it's
kids a hell of a player might be the
best player in the draft I love the kid
from Kansas a lot Jackson the ball is
terrific seem like a great kid I don't
think there's anybody in sports more
that I dislike more than mr. ball and I
don't know him as a person but I've
never seen a dad who think about this
what's a lot of time we asked to talk
about the kid ball I mean think about it
why cover Mars matters I watch that kid
play probably 15 times I demand this kid
is special he's really good but think
about for the last five months was a lot
of time we actually talked about the kid
and wasn't talking about his dad that
just pisses me off I mean the kids
special but
I'm not mention that kid in the last
five months maybe one time you mentioned
that kid is last five months
it's always been you I was talking about
some his dad said and I just think that
stuck to be honest with you if you're
magic and you know urban what do you
think he's thinking when he sees what
levar is you know strategizing and
saying and welcoming that into his house
now that he's got what you know I'm sure
he's been dreaming up for some time
which is control of the operations of
the Los Angeles Lakers joke well I think
magic it's the perfect person to tell
mr. ball to shut the hell up and stay
out of our gym you know it's going to
take a really strong person you know a
lot of these people are cowards when it
comes to telling players how to act you
know the players make so much money a
lot of these organizations are cowards
and they like the players do whatever
they want to they never win but Mary
Johnson to me is the perfect gadget hey
we appreciate your son you're going to
be a great player I stay at the gym
you're not coming to meetings you buy
season tickets just like the rest of the
parents do I think magic is one of the
few people it can do that
I think mr. ball would intimidate other
people and they'd be scared to dare me
get the hell out the gym so I actually
think it's a good situation I'm going to
the Lakers but I know Magic Johnson well
enough no hang on take no crap off
anybody and that said though Charles I
mean it seems that Lavar ball is playing
from a different playbook than most
wouldn't you think that he'd be the type
of guy that would go back at urban and
say he's my son and I'm a big baller if
you're not going to do this you don't
get to kick it
this ain't bring your Paris to work day
when you go to work you don't think your
dad that's that's not in any employment
manual in any job description you don't
get that's like remember a couple years
ago when the guy want to bring his kid
on all that into the locker room and on
all the trips and the players's and
gentleman said no you can't do that this
is not this is not high school when you
bring it you get a okay I'm gonna bring
my kid to work every day so no I think
magical magic angle have any of that
crap cue
should be pushing out to do that
actually I mean time for that dude to
step back and let his kids get some
shine stay out the week just because he
able to hold two points a game in
college he had his day well technically
he has a head is there ever two points a
game you ever had today the great
Charles Barkley a few more minutes with
him here on the show you find wood Shack
everything alright with you guys you and
Shane yeah uh yeah I like messing with I
love I love digging with the little
fella uh because you know he I told
somebody he got there the skin that's
last family and I like I like messing
with him and I and I just did just keep
turning and turning and I can just see
the veins in his pointed every time I
write about Colby and Dwayne and Alonso
and I just like nothing with him because
he got thin skin I told people he does
he got thinner skin the flats family and
I just and I'm just sitting there dying
laugh and he's getting so mad and but
we're always good man but I'm gonna keep
digging at him because I love the spirit
he well he was definitely sweating
there's no doubt about that
I mean how much further word you've gone
with like Mark Madsen smush Parker do
you need any more names or no the only
thing was really funny I ran out of name
that's because you know when I start
like obviously it's Wayne and Alonso and
those guys I should have taught you do
you see dollars Haslam in there I think
Jason Williams might a bit on that team
I tell you what though yeah I heard some
people talking about what you just said
if I couldn't came up with Smurfs Parker
that might have been the greatest name
ever
there's always tonight shows up there if
I could have come up with Smurfs Parker
I think I would have blew up the
Internet
well he did he did post a picture of him
blocking you today to keep this thing
going I guess is going into tonight so
I'm sure I listen I listen I can cut
listen I listen mark master you know I
can keep coming up with names if you
want to keep it going
- but you know such a thing that's funny
about him like he keeps it going if he's
still thinking about it I haven't
thought about it since I walked off the
set that night
keep that that's when you know that I
got there these people think about it
two days later
that's a slight Stanley that's the flag
yeah I'm like the people send me your
shack all right I'm like through what
you talking about what happened on the
ship
how do you do we're on TV having fun I
haven't thought about that since I
stepped off the show that night you're
like well smush Parker feel free to use
that tonight Charles we don't know how
about a hey rich I appreciate you giving
me that I like that Hey look okay so oh
wait are you busy right now with all
these OTAs going on sure well I mean the
big thing is the celebration penalty or
the ban on certain celebrations being
removed in the NFL what do you think
about that Charles you know I like
celebrations my what I'm hoping don't
happen is Aaron it would start trying to
come up with celebration like I think
celebrations are great for the game I
think they fun for the fan but what we
don't want to do is that player start
spending all their time coming up with
celebration whoo God give like three
touchdowns a year they should put caveat
in there if you have to have at least
have had double-digit touchdowns in your
career one year before you can celebrate
and you also have to be upright don't
you think have to be up on the
scoreboard you shouldn't be losing by a
test scores that's right yeah we should
come up with like uh it would be a fair
number cuz if you're down by seven or
ten or two touchdowns yeah yeah that's a
very file out you downed three
touchdowns or more you can't celebrate
right seriously you got to put if you
have never had double-digit touchdown in
I mean if some of these guys like
leaving even even in high school in
college if you haven't had double digits
you can't celebrate okay so if you're
down by double digits and your score
still keeps you within double digits no
good not as you can't do it that doesn't
be a perfect rule if your turns down
you're still down double digits
no celebrate just end it
all like Barry Sanders there to the
referee and if you break that you get
fined or penalized what do you think
well what we should you know we I I one
of the things I love doing when I was on
certain teams we had a kangaroo court
and well you have you get penalize of
doing stupid stuff if you do that that
should be a $2,500 file you have to put
into the kid if at the end of the year
party oh man I love chat with you
Charles have a good time tonight smush
Parker I'll be tuning in for that twist
Parker I appreciate it Mary thanks for
having me I'll keep up the great work
like likewise Charles love it okay thank
god they're gonna have a music so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that download our
app please just if it's a memory thing
just delete other apps you don't need
those apps this app the Rich Eisen show
app you need that